- [Kelly Clarkson] All right,
let's close out the
hour with something fun.
I found scrolling through social media.
This is what I'm liking!
(audience cheers)
All hour, we've been celebrating the world
of Super Mario Brothers,
because it's a great day.
Um, it's among plenty
of classic games kids
and many grownups are still
playing decades later,
after it came out.
Um, and one Utah mama is helping boys
and girls embrace their love of that game
and many more by teaching
video game, gaming classes.
Actually,
she says it helps kids
with problem solving and
confidence in a safe setting.
We have her on the line
right now watching on KSL TV.
Everybody give it up for Devin.
What's up, Devin?
(audience cheering)
- Hey Kelly.
How's it going?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Hello.
So basically, this is awesome.
You just teach kids how to
play video games, right?
How did you get into this?
- So I've been a gamer my entire life.
Remember playing Mario
on the Super Nintendo and
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah
- we moved to Utah, so
that my husband could go
to dental school, and I
knew I, we would need some
supplemental income to pay
for our four daughter's
dance classes and singing
classes and everything.
And so I started teaching online
and initially I was
teaching Spanish classes,
but instead of saying
like the apple is red
or the banana is yellow
I would say things like,
Mario is red and Pikachu is yellow.
And so my students
started asking me for help
in the games they're playing.
They're like, I'm stuck on this level.
Can you please help me?
And I said, well, you know what?
Why don't I make some video
game social clubs for us
and then I'll help you out with it.
And so now I teach about 18
video game social clubs a week.
My students are anywhere
from nine to 12 years old
and they get to come
and it's amazing because
it's a safe place where
they can game, you know?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- Video gaming can be really toxic.
And so in my classes
they know that they're
accepted and that it's safe.
- You're such a rad mom to do this.
What a cool mom you are.
So how do these classes work?
(audience clapping)
- So what we do in my classes is,
they'll sign up for a class.
So let's say they come
to a Mario Kart class
and I'll say all right guys,
today we're gonna play Mario Kart.
Let's do some races.
And I kind of turn it over to them.
I'm like, where do you guys
want to go on Mario Kart?
What should we do?
They're like, let's do
this level, let's do this.
And we have a great time
except they always seem to go after me.
I am the main target every
single time we play a game.
But it's so much fun.
I just, I love it.
It's the best job ever.
- Ah, that's so cool.
Thank you so much, Devin.
And hey, I'm gonna start
praying for your husband now,
that's a lot of women in one house
just saying
my thoughts and prayers for him.
I'm liking your post right now.
Right!
- Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Kelly. Thank you so much.
- Well, that's not all girl.
Our season long partner
Pilot Pen makers of G2,
the go-to pin of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanting to honor truly unstoppable people
just like yourself, ma'am.
So they're gonna write you a
check for a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
- Wow. Thank you.
Thank you so much, Kelly.
Appreciate it.
- [Kelly Clarkson]
Absolutely. Got a lot of kids.
So there you go. Thank you so much.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Chris Pratt, Jack Black, Charlie Day,
Keegan-Michael Key, Guy Branum,
and Meet Me at the Altar
Y'all have a great day
and well, if it's not
try and change it.